what red bull can't think red bull can't
but what size what how many ounces the
eight or the twelve i wanted to be where
i can't even wear a swimsuit because
people are gonna be like yo yo yo yo you
hanging
you're scaring all the kids yeah i want
to constantly be poking
you look like gonzo in a ski mask
get your life together
touch me bro i'm not touching you dude
you know mirroring exactly like i put
all like you know like a little things
of that and i'm just you know like it's
like a oh like a super impression of me
over all of them just like you know
making podcasts hot
that'll
oh you're wearing your wrestling [ __ ]
i like how the belly is a little
oh steve this is not flattering at all
them high school days ran my high school
body gone
how do i lift up yeah
you look like you're ready to go man
how much did you weigh when you wrestled
in high school uh
i had to cut like not three yep so 103
but would you walk around 117. and what
do you weigh now
1
34. oh yeah okay
yeah yeah yeah
17 is like a
dude a victoria's secret model yeah
my five-year-old's gonna give you a
handful man yeah one seven two look okay
though for happy yeah i mean
you know
i can't lose some
[Laughter]
does it bring back old memories of the
wrestling days putting that thing on it
did when i was in the room
i i kind of got a little adrenaline rush
yeah i got those nerves
you were ready to go that was the most
like
kind of nervous
i would get like for sure you know what
i mean like before about like a dual
meet or
either for cif or masters before you go
to state those are the most i'll have to
bring nerve-racking i have to bring my
high school basketball pictures in oh
damn what position you're playing
i don't look like that
forward see that was
i think i have one on my own and that
and that's uh oh that's bob on the left
with the yeah
yeah
look at bobby oh he was real he was a
guy
yeah
he's tall yeah
look checking him out so look at you too
though but steve still sort of looks
like that yeah he does well no that was
a lot skinnier there no no but you still
you could see 20 pounds getting in that
shape right now yeah we could
take some time you
what 20 pounds away from that yeah man
and you don't do anything
like one meal a day
oh mad no but we're talking about
physique we're not talking about like
working by running what if i hike up you
know start hiking up to start you know
what i mean yeah man coconut water i got
to get my [ __ ] together you look good
man yeah it's uh kind of in response to
last week's discussion guys are stirring
up the pot
my brother what do you guys think what
what we said who would win
yeah
you guys made a whole post about it i'm
trying to get in with like i hardly see
the guy anymore
so 62 said stevie would beat him up yeah
i i do think i mean it came from the
king of the sting instagram so it might
be a little biased of our our fans but
uh yeah i don't know everybody's doing
these boxing matches like we got to set
something up oh yeah you guys could
print money i'd love to see that you
guys could
wrestle about
cause theo hit me up he he wanted me to
bring up a couple things what about me
and you
doing a wrestling match steve i will
kick your ass
don't let my don't let my soft demeanor
fool you but if there's one possibility
yes that he has that dad's strength yeah
man
only if he
came down to my weight class what
happened
he'd have to cut his leg off exactly
well how much do you weigh i mean you
know i've never been a hundred anything
so you're i was your size in seventh
grade stevie
do you think that's a good idea in high
school i was a hundred seven 175 pounds
was the yeah i've ever been so that's
not a lot of
weight you'd have to cut all the way i
would have to cut the entire person
steve
but dude i think that would be a good
steve you have you have some advantages
you're quicker so you don't need to cut
weight no i'm not gonna be able to catch
you but if once i get you i'm doing it
i'm just dropping you i know i know that
but he told me to bring it up hilarious
why is he trying to stir the pot from
from tennessee how about
how about how about you and theo go at
it man because dio does some jiu jitsu
fancy himself uh well how much does theo
weigh because you know weight there's
probably one 170 180 seven he might be
all that might be 210. nah he yeah he's
all ass
yeah he was all ass in the head he's got
a fat ass he's a giant head jacket
he's not here today because he's
murdering fish he got really into
fishing
and he got here king of the sting
no so uh we actually had some fans weigh
in on who who they think would win and
why
uh
let's see this guy he said don't judge
him he he sent this in at like three in
the morning he was hammered yeah this is
what jesus looks like now god does i
would eat steve in order to be famous
steve you say you wouldn't yeah
is it even a question
bob bob would eat steve in order to be
famous
steve
wouldn't he say he's saying bob would go
literally do anything yeah i like this
guy
i think he knows what he's talking about
keep playing this i love him theo eric
stevie i think hands down in a fight my
man stevie wiebe's gonna take it from
bobby grab him by the nuts give him that
crazy look that's it stevie got this
gang buzz buzz yeehaw baby oh damn would
you grab him by the nut stevie this is a
great i love
today's
i love what you're doing
i love her keep going
g'day boys it's gojo from down under i
reckon the fight between stevie and
bobby obviously uh you think bobby would
come out on top probably end up sitting
on stevie's face
but the good thing about stevie is you
probably like it suck the soul round out
of him it doesn't matter really who wins
because bobby gets to go home to that
dime bag he's sitting on so uh
everyone's a winner in that fight scares
breaking gang gang butt muffler all
right time stamp that
officer
delete that
yeah
i don't need that visual
individual steve eating bobby's butt no
seriously
we got one more shout out to australia
though
well this can't get the hold up
yes yeah
it looks like it's all swag too like he
got it
yeah
so wearing bravo television gym shorts
yeah he has a fight pass wristbands
[Laughter]
yo what's going on with that band rouge
baddie with the fatty theo vaughn okay
brendan actually just saw you in san
jose man almost called usada i just
wanna give a quick little shout out to
both uh montez and uh nick as well go
pat go
uh the reason i'm making the video
though is because our homie stevie man
that dude would beat the [ __ ] out of
bobby lee man the reason being is he's
just smarter you know we kind of see
what he did in the movie the goonies the
way he uses his brain thank you
this guy's the best
i know his name data same guy he's
short-ranged data same dude i respect
him
and his name was kequan i'm a fan oh
okay it seems like the majority of it's
a little biased it's our our fans but
everyone thinks you would beat the
shadow i would have to ask uh you know
whatever no but this is just because
bobby's a little out of shape no but the
thing is that he has that psychological
older brother
you know what that that means i feel you
you know what i mean you have a brother
yeah oh my brother you know what i mean
he's got that yeah the psychological
older brothers [ __ ] yeah
did bobby used to whip your ass growing
up yeah me too he'd whoop my ass i won
one fight against him oh bob would just
whip my ass yeah what's different now
well i got a lot of rage in me i don't
do anything
is there any resentment steve is there
any part of you now that's like do you
ever think about it when things are
going on you think maybe i need to like
get one in just to like let him know
things are different
what do you mean by that like you know
what he means his success
no like revenge yeah yeah oh if that
were to happen it wouldn't be like hey
dude meet me on the street it would be
like planned out like
you'd like shank like bombs like hitting
like a car bomb like a drone it would be
i feel like you're a droner you're a
drone
if i were rich i'd buy the house like
above his
and then i would just throw eggs at his
pool like yeah
i'm above you brother
brother
today's king and the sting is brought to
you by athletic greens it's important to
be healthy ask my boy george over here
look at george swelled up man swolled up
george and listen he got there with a
little help from athletic greens they
can help their daily all-in-one
superfood powder is by far the easiest
most delicious nutritional habit that
you can add to your health routine today
all right take ownership of your health
one tasty ass scoop of athletic greens
contains 75 vitamins minerals whole food
source ingredients including
multivitamins multi minerals probiotics
green superfood blend and so much more
athletic greens got you covered man all
you gotta do simply visit
athleticgreens.com cats that's
athleticgreens.com kats and join the
health experts athletes health conscious
big boys thick boys comedians podcasters
athletes whoever it is they're all about
health with athletic greens
athleticgreens.com
kats get your free year supply of
vitamin d and five free travel packs
today
week one might be over but the season is
just getting started kids draftkings
sportsbook an official sports betting
partner of the nfl and ufc to kick off
week two draftkings has given new
customers 200 and free bets instantly
when they bet one dollar at any football
game listen up because you don't want to
miss this week two head to the
draftkings sportsbook app now place a
bet on one dollar on any week two game
to receive 200 in free bets instantly if
sportsbook is not available in your
state draftkings still has huge cash
prizes up for grabs all season long with
their daily fantasy contests draftking's
giving all new customers a free shot at
millions of dollars in total prizes with
their first deposit download draftking
sportsbook app now use the promo code
kats to receive two hundred dollars in
free bets when you place a one dollar
bet on any week two football game that's
promo code kats this week's at draftking
sportsbook an official sports better
partner of the nfl must be 21 older new
jersey indiana pennsylvania only you're
22 right you're good to go doug
new customers only minimum five dollar
deposit one dollar wager required one
per customer restriction supply
for details gambling problem call call
one eight hundred gambler or indiana one
eight hundred nine with it
you were you only childish yeah i was
the only child so you don't know yeah i
don't know how this i don't know
anything about this nothing yeah you
know it's just like it was just like
people at my high school or whatever you
have like little beefs with people but
it was never like that kind of closeness
that you love that love and hate them
yeah yeah yeah but when you grow older
you know you that just nick you had an
older sister right two older sisters
yeah would they be the shadow of you uh
yeah yeah yeah
really and then i finally got big enough
when i was like seventh grade and
they're like seniors juniors like i
can't hit a girl no i like i like put my
sister in an arm rock arm lock because i
i watch a lot of wrestling and i hurt
her arm and then we never fought again
because i felt really really bad as an
only child from a single parent my mom
i remember when my mom
couldn't spank me anymore
like i remember
like the day that you know she tried to
hit me with something and i was like ow
come on i was like mom we're done with
this
well in middle school we're done yeah
you know you know because i remember
time she was like okay i had to grab my
mom by the arms yeah you know i was like
mom and i did like this i was like
please
stop there's something you do
please stop sit down and then my mom
just what are you gonna do
i was like i'm not gonna do anything but
it's like yeah you need to stop like my
mom used to go in there's other ways to
go about this i remember there used to
be like this tree in our backyard and
she would make me get a switch off the
tree to spank me with it goddamn yeah it
was your mom adrian peterson yeah it was
yeah
yeah
and so like i remember i'll never forget
like
she was like go out there and go get me
something that you know and you couldn't
come back with like a little i already
i've already done that i had to come
back with like enough
i'm not there testing it
but then i i went back there and they
had cut the tree down you know like
whoops so i had to come back in and i
was scared you know and then when i told
her they cut it down we both started
laughing and i was like oh i didn't get
a beating yeah and i was like ooh i
think that's one of the first times i
thought i can get away with stuff with
humor being funny yeah yeah and then we
just had this little hallway that we you
know it was like two doors at the end
and we could like i could run around
like this so she would chase me when she
wanted to give me a spanking and then i
remember that time too she started
laughing and we were laughing
and then it was like there was no spa
you know and it was like oh okay there's
something to this yeah it is weird as a
peer i remember my brother was such a
bad kid and he was talking [ __ ] about my
stepmom to my dad we were at cherry
creek mall and he was like 16. you're
not going to spank a 16 year old my dad
straight up pushed him into a glass wall
i was like i will [ __ ] you up like
you're 16 now we i will straight up
fight you and i was like oh damn dad
ain't [ __ ] around anymore your older
brother yeah older brother sometimes you
need i mean you need that oh my god i
was like
hey [ __ ] yeah there's no
spanking we're gonna fight yeah
sometimes oh you know bob fought my dad
at once oh really yeah how'd that go
your dad would be during he was like in
and out of rehab and they're fighting in
the hallway and then i just heard
commotion in the hallway and i'm like
well there's what's going on and i open
the door
and they're doing like flying
multi-ni they're like doing flying dad
was like [ __ ] looking like
each other up in the hallway
and i'm like that's when i like i gained
respect for bob i'm like oh he's like
fighting back
yeah the game works right now
woody beat downs beat down chin you had
an older brother you used to beat your
ass he beat me up like twice and then i
never messed with him again you called
your gang members no do it again do it
again no brother they drove up on it
but he bloodied your nose up
uh he's actually pretty cool he would i
would hit try to hit him in the face he
would just hit me in the body he knew he
would [ __ ] me up
yeah just break a quick rib you know he
was cool he knew what was going on he
knew he was bigger than you it could be
he knew he could beat me up he knew he
could beat up a lot of people too just
very shy was that big dude
uh he's actually smaller than me but
he's just
super wide is he in prison now no he's
actually built like chun ling
chief executive director of it damn oh
wow all right
oh he spelled like white chocolate
all right calm down he said jail how to
protect my brother
[Laughter]
like what no so none of this there's a
gank well i don't want to mention any
gang names obviously i'm sorry just but
it was like
filipinos and koreans it was very mixed
filipinos and koreans oh fico's what was
the name of it
there was name there's no i'll tell you
later
yeah okay yeah just you could erase it
yeah yeah i don't care because they're
gonna be like
why are you snitching i know i'm talking
about the show okay so
let's get to these tips
and send me to britney spears
a couple weeks ago uh people always send
me this too uh see we saw three fields
yeah theo getting thirsty in the
comments and he was at it again she's
some tits on her dog yeah she's what
she's done now she's like you know well
now she's free from it's abroad now you
know what i mean yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah he's trying so hard
and she's gotta notice because he gets
so many likes on the post you know what
does yamia mean her tits oh
you know what's hilarious though is like
i actually think
i can see
theo when britney spears getting
together he could definitely do that
like
you would nonchalantly be like yeah man
last week guys with britney spears house
man you do that all the time yo he gets
crazy all the time he gets crazy no but
it's not even about that it's about
those two personalities i think
you mean two crazies getting together
yeah he'd have her put the the catholic
school thing on yeah
and she'd be up there do that oops again
girl
for me
[Laughter]
he's told a story about how one time he
was staying at i believe it was lindsay
lohan's hotel and he slipped a note
under her door
at the hotel
she's like oh my god but she got a hold
remember that list she put out remember
how she was like like telling everybody
all the dudes that she slept with oh no
oh yeah man lindsay lohan had a whole
list she was like it was like ryan
phillippe or like that kind of those
kind of people how many dudes were on it
a lot it was like a lot of famous dudes
why did she write that list i don't know
she's just bragging good for her these
are all the people that have been in me
theo wasn't on the list
uh we'll we'll check it out but she is
engaged evidently yeah yeah she's
engaged oh theo's gonna be broken hard
oh man theo could take that guy i don't
know what's that guy dude looks like
he's an actor right he's like some kind
of sort of famous actor is he yeah i
don't i think he's like a model that's
it but her her dad doesn't have
conservative ship anymore right you know
this is what i think happened so they
trying to get him out right so he
actually petitioned to end the
conservative ship for her you know why
because they're looking at litigation no
i i think it's like this too i think she
said to him hey listen
they're gonna kick you out and you're
gonna be on the streets and once i get
out of this conservatorship i'm not
giving you nothing yep you you're gonna
be out of my life forever so now why
don't you uh petition to get this done
and then you know you can still be my my
dad and see what what i mean is the the
firm that that her dad hired to like run
her instagram and do all the publicity
they have the intention they do it
that's what they do to make her look
crazy yeah so they run her social media
stuff like that and they found out that
the dad and the mom were just siphoning
money from her like just taking it of
course so she's gonna sue the [ __ ] out
what happens all the time in hollywood
well here's the thing though that
money's going on holy coke and all that
they ain't siphoning in the money to
save it it's not in a 401k that stuff is
in like he probably got it on his wrist
yep it's probably in their house and all
this kind of stuff they probably got
expenses now yep they probably live in a
lifestyle where they need that money
that shit's gonna stop and she's like
nah cut them off this is a trap this is
lindsay lohan's list yeah why are some
names blurred out i'm assuming they're
not famous people just guys
justin timberlake oh these are heavy
hitters god if you're not a famous
person like damn
i was underneath justin timberlake no
i'm just gonna be like well you know i'm
number ten
how do you know
these are all heavy hitter uh actors
yeah uh
she was dope at a time
yeah
during mean girls
is now is that jay phoenix joaquin
phoenix
who are these other guys max george who
are these other dudes
i don't know adam levine adam levine
nico which one's adam levine he's uh you
know the uh the on on the voice room
five room five the singer so yeah it's
hilarious i know him more from the voice
than maroon five
damn that's crazy that they have a list
like this solid list i'll list yeah but
when you're here man now i was like
goddamn but when you famous like that
though when you're famous like that you
you around other famous people they're
always like intertwining for sure yeah
yeah you're not getting some regular and
the craft foods and the dick suck you
know yeah she's just like yo
good for her yeah i know i don't hate
him
i mean
look at what i wonder what justin
timberlake's list look like you know the
difference justin timberlake's this will
be like you know shelly from cvs
dudes lists are completely different
besides some good kinger stingets and
debate clubs we got some updates from
some fans that found the show we'll get
to later but first we'll get to some
weekend news
i remember this little diamond yeah this
is trying to hook her up with a
firefighter and she went with that one
dude from uh minnesota who's this oh is
this
the first ever contestant on the cat's
dating game oh she giving us an update
yeah yeah and she threw out a debate
club at the end but the update is really
the interesting part let's hear it king
listing theo brennan eric and stevie i'm
happy to be on the show again with
another relationship update i'm sure you
guys are tired of hearing from me
but finally after months of some super
freaky dms on instagram i got a random
text from the love of my life
parker my ex-boyfriend and
you're right
all right we've never been happier that
was the guy we just got engaged last
week and we are super excited so
wish us the best cool thank you
but anyways we have a little bit of a
debate club yeah before we get into
debate club getting engaged knowing each
other for two months no no this is the
guy that we had on the show this was her
original boyfriend that didn't want to
wipe her up oh so she she went on the
show he must have caught word she said
she he wasn't a fan but uh yeah he he
must have been like what all these
interests
[Music]
now we also see the kind of guy she
likes yep i mean this dude is like
freaking alpha [ __ ] a thor yeah
and
he evidently
drove 10 hours yeah he dropped the ring
damn
damn doggy yes you might read that
caption it says after a 10-hour drive
surprising her hair she said yes i love
you so much oh that's sweet good grief
look at that see cats making it happen
dog i like to think that was us yeah all
of us well for sure because we put her
on the market
yeah and he's like what the [ __ ] yeah
how'd you think this one dude's just
trying to get her
weird
he seems like a good dude
glad it worked out yeah good for him
good for both of them
but anyways we have a little bit of a
debate club for you guys
which you care less about the met gala
or the bmas
personally i didn't know what the hell
the met gala was until savannah just
explained it to me so
i could care less about them
[Laughter]
what do you guys think also rip some of
these drips for us
i could care less about it i could care
less about either one well i do watch
the vmas from start to finish really
honestly i can't see mcgregor almost
going to fight with machine guns
listen the met gallop for attacks
original layers here's the thing with
this the met gala they always wear [ __ ]
that you could never wear and you can
you just wear it once what is it like
where's pete dave's gonna wear that
again where the [ __ ] you gonna wear that
dress again dude but what is it what is
it for me gal is like the big fashion
like i think it's 55 000 a table
something like that it's so expensive
it's just a fashion show to have rich
people jerk each other but the rich
people wear [ __ ] like
like they're wearing horns with diamonds
like you're never going to wear that
it's like a hot well high fashion is
like you never see high fashion ever
that correlates to the real world yeah
never it's crazy and look at that aoc
attack
meanwhile she's rich and she paid 55
grand to be there so they just wear the
outfit once that's jlo i mean god damn
jayla killing it
fifth okay she looks stunning that's
what i'm saying i mean look at hey
fitty yeah
[Music]
when you got money like i wonder how
much she spends on her body like getting
herself you know trainers and chefs uh
you know what i mean she got probably
got to cry
oxygen thing in her place does she look
good or what
yeah
oh see that's good too she's just crazy
they all look good and then and then uh
kim kardashian she always has to do
something super crazy what does she do
like everybody else dresses all normal
and she's like you know what i'm gonna
take another dude i'm gonna drop her
i don't know why the kardashians get so
much hate like kim kardashian she ain't
regular fine
she's fine
yeah
is she really that funny yeah man she
just said she got something about her
let me see your butt you know what you
know it's kind of crazy but let me see
the butt
the kardashian butt okay
you know what you know what's weird
though is with travis scott
getting with kylie jenner right
she's flying too now now now but god
don't play that plastic surgeon [ __ ]
like that like remember she was a basic
ass white girl before all these
surgeries then travis scott has a baby
with her that baby comes out doesn't
look nothing like her she has so much
work done
who wore it better
[Laughter]
that's just for publicity right they
want attention she yeah should do
anything for me yeah yeah yeah tax the
rest tax the rich meanwhile the rich pay
for all your taxes yeah that's what kim
wore
okay so that's okay
and kanye were the same thing that
like they got a weird relationship huh
the weirdest you know yeah
you think they still booty calling every
now and then oh yeah imagine showing up
to an event like this all right
do they have normal butts do they get um
did they get operations
all four so how do they get their butts
bigger they inject some kind of inject
fat they take fat from their tummies to
put in their ass okay damn i just want
to do that but i put it all in my dick
just a big fat ass dick that i can't
even control
yeah yeah it's going to be like
just just you know what i mean just take
it off take it all from my belly and
just jam it after me like this thanks
david like this is about to have thick
or long lengths both so you want girth
and length yeah doug i think uh but i
think that i think women you should put
a pole for that because i think women
would say thickness over length they
don't want you because it's real long
and skinny like a twizzler you ain't
doing [ __ ] yeah you're gonna hurt
somebody's inside how thick do you want
it though
i mean you know like no i don't know
like like like red bull can't think like
a red bull you know the red
but what size what how many ounces the
eight or the twelve i wanted to be where
i can't even wear a swimsuit because
people are gonna be like yo yo yo you
hanging
you're scaring all the kids yeah i want
to constantly be poking
you look like gonzo in a ski mask
but how long do you want it what's
too long
over 12 inches
if it's thick enough as long as you're
around six i'd say yeah is that good six
i mean i don't know what about five and
a half yeah we gotta get the we have to
get the we have to get the female cats
uh people to like let us know it's five
and a half ok
it's all good
like where are you going
where are you going to wear that again
just do this we're the [ __ ]
fabulous he is he is just fabulous
like good for him he's really he's
leaning into this stuff so he has a lot
of sugar that takes cuts man he's really
doing it does it
yeah man
how can you walk that's his thing
yeah this dude's a queen of england
right now
yo man i see a lot of you bros at my
shows a lot of you are losing some hair
you're not losing your hair dude george
you look good dude you got a full set of
hair a lot of people aren't so fortunate
man two out of three bros will
experience some form of hair loss by the
time that they're 35 more than 50
million dudes in the us suffer from male
pattern baldness thank god for keeps
keeps offers a simple stress-free way to
keep your hair alright it's low-cost
treatments are just ten dollars per
month all right discrete little package
shows up to the crib nobody has to know
proven results keeps has more five-star
reviews than any of its competitors
prevention is the key here kids
treatment can take four to six months
see results so act right now if you're
ready to take action prevent your hair
from leaving so you look like george
costanza go to
go to
keps.com cats to receive your first
month of treatment for free that's
keeps.com cats to get your first month
free k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash cats listen man there's
always something to celebrate but you
gotta do it the right way y'all a lot of
y'all buying them fake diamonds out
there you don't need to do that anymore
man because thanks to bluenile.com
you can celebrate all of life's special
moments from engagement rings all right
lifetime pieces it's not going to break
the bank because we got you covered man
uh with your customizing engagement ring
like my boy eric griffin all right you
want some diamond stud errands to flex
on some of these kids out there
bluenow.com you're in control we got you
covered man again build the engagement
ring of her dreams just don't go the
store get any old ring
customize that bad [ __ ] do it man life
special moments with fine jewelry they
have a vast selection preset diamond
gemstone jewelry blue now offers endless
options ready to ship the same day we
got you covered man bluenile.com is
original online jeweler since 1999
they've helped millions of couples
create their perfect engagement ring so
that could be you man again if it
doesn't come out perfect no problem 100
satisfaction guaranteed shop stress free
with guaranteed free shipping returns
all right
make the moment sparkle with jewelry
from bluenow.com and king of the sting
listeners and viewers get 50 bucks off
this uh 500 bucks this is a podcast
exclusive exclusive offer includes
engagement use code kats that's code
cats plus every order is insured ships
free arrives in discreet little package
that won't give away what's inside shop
stress free find your forever piece go
to bluenow.com today
uh she's got a debate club she's been on
here before right yeah she mentions it
guys long time no see it is jesse from
cleveland and i came back down from the
pole to bring your debate yeah she's a
stripper that's right now i know y'all
had to have seen that video of mcgregor
and mgk going at it on the red carpet
and i've gotta ask between the two who
do you think is the bigger star
i might have said mcgregor before but
lately mgk just seems like he keeps
winning and can't be stopped and
literally has america's hottest check
wrapped around his finger
and then mcgregor is over here like kind
of going off the rails a bit seems like
he's dabbling a little too hard in the
blockade if you ask me
and he was the one who went up to mgk
allegedly for the photo before [ __ ] hit
the fan
so
i might be a little biased since i'm a
cleveland girl myself but i i want to
hear it from y'all
go go with that eastside cleveland wild
boy or are you going to go with the
notorious mma i know i'm not over here
drinking the proper 12. so let's hear
from y'all what a great commission
she's great yeah
uh so with mj mgk thing and conor
mcgregor so just so you guys know so
there's rumors that they're both at the
red carpet the rumor is that
connor asked for uh megan fox picture
yeah yeah mgk was like get the [ __ ] out
of here yeah and then his bodyguards
like you know got all crazy bumped into
connor spilled a drink that's when
connor's like [ __ ] this he's a fighter
yeah like you bring in a bite a pit bull
the red carpet you can do some people
[ __ ] he threw a freaking dolly yeah at a
bus
oh he broke the window dude yeah
so i look who's more famous
uh connor conor mcgregor worldwide and
you know why too that's the only reason
why we're talking about this correct if
that was some random or that was like
adam levine yeah it wouldn't matter it
would be like they would it would just
be like you know stars fight but the
reason why we're even mentioning it or
even like
because it's a debate is the headlines
all over yeah yeah
it's crazy you guys watch the interviews
after they they interview
individuals i watch it all they ask dude
denied everything he's like i don't know
what happened no conor was like i don't
know that i don't know he's like you
take a picture with me i don't know he
called him like he's like all i know is
he's a what he said a vanilla white boy
rapper megan fox i i know megan fox
that's what he said yeah but how about
that who's more famous machine gun kelly
or megan fox megan fox well as a
combination
megan foxman famous for that yeah yeah
she'll be famous for a minute
she's still fine i like machine guns
i think kelly won because she catches
composure she got kids with someone else
90210 boy oh right yeah uh uh shawn
austin yeah brian brian oh yeah ryan
austin yeah yeah
set this up and if i get my money no way
no
connor would take him down
just because of experience yeah but this
is about this one at this point i made
on below the belt
the lines are blurred for whatever
reason because this celebrity like
fighting right where people think like
these fighters like
[ __ ] the smallest guy in the world
like henry cejudo would beat the living
[ __ ] out of machine gun kelly well you
don't realize the level these fighters
are at oh yeah but people will be here
because the lines are blurred yeah the
celebrity thing everyone's like oh
machine gun kelly's taller like oh my
god
double leg right through double leg [ __ ]
wrestling no you knocked him out dude
well
would
anybody would anybody with any
professional
beat the [ __ ] out of him not even close
mop the floor without the wrestling or
grappling don't need any of it any of it
connor's one of the greatest strikers
we've ever had but imagine if you added
that into the mix it doesn't need to he
would just knock him out walk off home
but henry his neo 125.
he's a little guy doesn't matter how big
is machine gun kelly six five he's like
how much does he weigh 180 180 way
bigger and he's way bigger doesn't
matter see that's the problem doesn't
matter see this is the problem with the
common fan here's the thing though
i'm i agree with you but 180 like he
gonna get some hits in
no
you don't you won't get one hit
if they're not but they're not caught
they're not gonna reach what i'm saying
is this we're not talking about a fight
in the ring i'm talking about we out of
these streets
i think that you won't touch him you
don't think he's even going to hit him
he like i guess they've kind of like
grappled with them like you'd get like
some rabbit punches yeah
but he would throw a punch kind of slip
and oh that left hand you would notice
it just depends on the uh also the
resilience of the guy because i always
say i'm not a fighter but you better
kill me yeah right yeah you know what
i'm saying yeah like i'm just like i
just feel like you know
you fight for my life i gotta i yeah
you're right look 130 pounds okay
look
machine gun kelly was talking [ __ ] and
had bedazzled jewels on his jaw yeah
it's like and i and i like the hospital
right you break his jaw destroy him
knock him flat out but the reach doesn't
count like what if he went like like
just not when you're talking about a
regular civilian i'm just trying to play
devil's what if there's a [ __ ]
what are you what are you neo
because he was a leader steve thinks
he's in the mail
because he's a lazy guy doesn't matter
he plays the guitar what's going on here
this is that lei who submitted that yeah
just so you can see
what is going on here this is the person
who just submitted you got to go to
cleveland that's her yep
listen to she's playing the thick boy
that's not here
[Music]
yep
[Music]
got real tight all the time
[Laughter]
he's smuggling egg rolls in your [ __ ]
singletail you're going at it over here
man we got this a sausage party
this got real gay up in there
that's art dude
as he's watching i'm like why is he
grabbing his dick
we need to leave you alone for a second
you sure you don't have that black butt
in the car you want to go make a trip
real quick okay guys eyes
okay we can't put stevie in a singlet
yeah yeah
i should wear this every week huh yeah
no no more onesies for you steve no more
onesies or no more strippers yeah hey
theo told me to bring up some points so
i took notes so he called me this
morning oh no yeah yeah cause i want to
forget nick he told me to ask you guys
how do i become one of the big dogs what
do you mean big dogs you know like what
level you guys are on you know what
level is that yeah but you know like you
know you are bigger
oh [ __ ]
look what he's trying to stamp that i
mean he's almost like he's over here
almost saying like yeah ask him how can
we like how can i get a good girl or
something yeah he's trying to like he's
trying to clown us that's what he's
doing well is that psychological like
that yeah he's trying to do some
psychological warfare i didn't realize
that but you get to our level but you're
like a trojan horse but you don't do
stand up yeah that's right i don't i
mean if you did i'm sure we could help
but yeah you tried though steve did try
to do stand up for a couple months yeah
yeah what didn't you like about it well
i i choked majorly uh opened up for bob
at the temple i already told this story
you opened up for bob at tempe improv
yeah that's not a small role i choked
hard but it was your first time you're
not supposed to be good steve bob said
you're up for failure he knew yeah have
fun out there like what i've never done
it yeah yeah tempi improv yeah and you
just forgot your jokes and like no i did
a whole cowboy wrap thing and i oh and
then i was just i didn't even
acknowledge the crowd i just went into
my bed
and then oh you you didn't be like
what's up everybody just started them
i'm just like
forty dollar bidder for you know i was
doing this little cowboy thing and the
mc had to rescue me from the stage did
bobby help you with your set yeah do
that what happened is i went to the
green room and the manager went up to
bob and said
yeah the next two shows your brother's
out
and so bob's like dude
you could drive home dude you're free to
go
and then i went to del taco
got some tacos and he texted my mom so i
got a fight with my mom in the kitchen
what are you doing
why you do that i go you don't know
comedy mom
and then i then later that night i went
into the room my brother just knocked on
the door and he wanted to help me write
jokes and i'm like you don't understand
my branded comedy dude yeah i'm advanced
yes you know so i was really yeah you
don't take notes well it's stubborn
and that's actually still a problem yeah
sounds like no i'm chase
he's like get the [ __ ] out of my room
you don't know comedy
all right you got to do a big fight with
me i'm mindful
look what are you talking about
have you had any desire to go back on
stage not really i mean we're doing me
and jeremiah doing the podcast live
event
similar but
yeah that's similar to it yeah would you
but i think
i think he should do it again 100 you
know i think you should and you should
break that same set no no no no no
listen that same set with your new
sensibility and make it work that's the
challenge i want that cowboy round maybe
don't do it in front of the giant sold
out two songs it was the dude
you know how you the green room is they
were in front of the club yeah i had to
walk by the audience members you
panicked they didn't even look at me
they just look like oh you know what the
challenge is i challenged theo to take
steve under his way under his wing take
him on one of those two or three minutes
one of those at one of his shows and
have have steve open for theo you know
what's up
since you want to send him that's how he
can become a big dog yeah
theo there you go why don't you help him
be a big dog you're the big dog he means
like big dog in like uh podcasting i
don't know it was very vague
yeah he just he called we talked for
like a couple minutes like i mean you're
doing it
scissor bros you're on here people love
you on here like you're doing it he's
like the master manipulator
who's who's the manipulator
yeah yeah he's the puppy yeah he's like
trying to puppet master some [ __ ] right
here okay
the challenge back
make steve a big dog take him to one of
you don't you take a break from killing
fish and get your ass on the show how
about that yeah back to king interstate
okay
continue
uh this guy's got a counter saying it
related to our discussion of engagements
last week all right
what's going on you guys this is wyatt
calling in from north carolina so
brennan stevie and eric i gotta king it
or sting it for you guys
hitting that proposal in front of
that culvers
king understand it let me know
uh i don't know what culver's is well
what is culver's it's a frozen custard
burger
yeah it's like sonic from the looks of
these two this was right on point
nothing would make her happy yeah this
was like does he have like a bart star
jersey it's ray nichky actually nick can
you look it's huge in wisconsin yeah
yeah where is culver's where is it
originating uh wisconsin so this is what
i'm saying it looks like that might have
been their first date yeah this is their
fifth yeah this is like that's their
thing oh it's like in and out burger but
out there yeah this is on brand yes
yeah oh that's not my one he's in a
packers jersey yeah yeah she clearly
just got a double double wrong with it
yeah no he had connects though he got it
on the marquee oh he did so that's extra
effort yeah he went all out
listen i have no problem with this
this is like it seems personal yeah
that's what it's all about yeah king it
yeah
because you know what it ain't about
like some big gesture that we think is a
big gesture it's about him knowing his
chick and him knowing what what what is
personal and it's from his heart it's
from his heart dressing up with that
throwback packer
i like that personalized yeah so this is
this is beautiful it's the whole thing
yeah i feel the love in this how did you
get how did you go over to the signage
though he's like oh let's check this out
oh the manager's probably playing yeah
he planned it yeah that's his planning
dude he planned this out yeah and maybe
she's like eric's fiance and she keeps
making them do different ones tomorrow
they're at arby's right right
they're hitting the buffet
the next time it's the monday night
football game packers yeah yeah
hopefully aaron rodgers
all right i mentioned uh we have another
update from one of our fans uh bmi
george who started how's the big boys
trying to lose the weight yeah yeah
remember he wanted to wrestle you know
he's my buddy i like the kid he's a good
dude i like everybody i thought you
still got to do a job my quick question
though um steve
uh is the chub gone are you still hiding
it like yeah like if you have to wrestle
right now could you wrestle that boner
like if the teacher called you up to the
front of the class could you read
without could you go sharpen your pencil
in sixth grade
oh man
you're making me blush
you're making us
and then i see this like you know this
sort of phallic symbol in front of you
it's like this is a whole i see that
[ __ ] spring roll in your pants though
she should have shown me that video of
the the pole dance she's bad no he's
still going that was badass she's she's
you know she's a bad boy
keep sending videos so phoebe gets a
book i'm gonna need you to send that to
him later you know what real talk i
didn't masturbate last night okay well
there it is guys well there we go hello
there we go thank you let's see george
let's see what he's got there you go
george
hey bubbas what's up
long time no see
[ __ ] is that post malone it's been a
journey it's great
june 1st i started this
451 bro
ever since then
with brendan's inspiration and the rest
of the crew i freaking i've just been
kicking ass
trying my best to at least
i can
today's the day
let's see what this says
260. he started out with three what was
he 451 holy [ __ ] good for him okay
here's the issue there ain't no issue
that's progress toenail
260. there you go
that's 190 pounds down hell yeah dude
come get yourself
260.
of course
i challenge that little
disgusting
greasy
stevie what are you talking about
freaking weebly
i'm coming little did you know you have
a rock heart
i'll be there i'm gonna hit you with a
little oh
something something you ain't even gonna
understand damn me as wrestlemania see
you soon bubba
i love you both oh
i got love for him
we're gonna have a oh
[ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
you look great
a lot of hard work man
looking great bro that's [ __ ] great
dude yeah when'd you get in i got in
yesterday about eight in the morning
nick you son of a [ __ ]
looking good how are you feeling man i'm
feeling beautiful how are you doing it
like how did you keto kid baby okay so
what is keto
uh no carbs no sugar
yeah protein fat how do you not eat
sugar though like honestly you try
really yeah you really gotta you know
you gotta die isn't it about like not
eating
more like like that you know they say
more sugar because like does that mean
no fruit
yeah fruits yeah for i just don't do
fruit at all because obviously i got to
be in my surgery so my tummy is real
tiny what's it bmi what is that so
that's when they take out a majority of
your stomach
and they just make your stomach real
small and they take out the part of your
stomach that produces the uh i'm hungry
hormone yeah so it's like a hormonal
surgery as well damn it's done wonders
for you man you feel good
i feel great i mean most people
aren't as you know young and energetic
as me willing to kick ass like this
i've literally been working out six days
a week i've been
i haven't cheated
at all good for you man like i like i
know you don't try but brendan you have
literally just by being you and the
human you are inspired me and to really
shape in like who i become as an adult
and as a man like i don't i don't have a
lot of male role models in my life and
you're badass brother do you find that
this is the hardest part now like so you
lost the 190 pounds yeah when you look
back on it you go like okay you lost
that
now this is the part where it's like how
do you go from this part to the next
part is that is that the challenge you
feeling it is a challenge because this
is obviously a brand new body and i
still want to get a little lower i'm
still trying to kick ass i'm i'm
thinking 230s sounds really nice
because i see like tom segura he looks
great at 2 30. he lost a lot of weight
but on top of that i have to put muscle
into this freaking yeah yeah yeah that's
the heart
it's like the challenge to me it becomes
like it's like there's one thing to lose
weight and then there's another thing to
work on your physique yeah like those
are two different things right very
different things 100 yeah so it's like
so then it's like now you're in that
process of like trying to figure out
okay so i know how to lose weight but
how do i you know yeah like because
there's gonna have to be a time really
soon that i adjust to more proteins and
trying to pack on more muscle put the
muscle on yeah the body up mm-hmm
how did you discover um theo brendan to
begin with um
like most young lost 16 year olds i
watched a joe rogan podcast
i'm 22 now oh wow yeah so
yeah yeah
you ever tried dmt he's the male oprah
dog yes literally
you get some dmt
[Laughter]
everybody gets out
jamie look that up
but uh yeah it started with that and
obviously the fight companions which
brought
brendan and brian moore into it and then
when i saw that i was like there's more
than joe rogan podcast
because you know yeah there's rhythm
with griffin yeah
but uh then i got really into the
fighter and the kid
and
you know i don't know if you guys heard
but there was like something happened
one of the guests had to leave for a
while so yeah brendan was in tom
snapchat yeah yeah
he was brendan was going through a lot
in life yeah yeah and that's when he
brought like mike catherwood on and when
i saw brendan and mike together and they
got straight into fitness talking about
it i was like
oh like the people i love and look up to
and admire like they're going through
the same they want
brandon was 271 he wanted to write it on
his hands so they didn't forget yeah
sure yep so when i'd reach for that
cookie i'd see that too i'm like no good
for you i just didn't i just saw all of
this but i totally understand you're
saying because like i'm 49 years old and
i just i'm down in body fat in the last
like six months i'm down 40 pounds of
body weight why are you doing it you
know but it's just you just i'm just
eating better but like it's all about
that you know it's just but i understand
this like i know how you feel in a sense
of like it's like you know we we
ultimately want to be like
we just want to look good naked like
that's like that's really the goal right
you know what i mean i don't care what
people say everybody's like that when
they when they when they get undressed
when you get out of the shower you get
undressed you go in the shower you look
at yourself and you go god damn it oh
you look at yourself yeah that's
motivation you know and so i understand
because i even feel like i feel like i
know how this to feel insecure
even when you've lost out this way you
still feel like you're like damn man i
still want to work and that's the
hardest part so what keeps you motivated
like what keeps you like
are there ever moments where you're like
i don't want to do this or like every
day
every day i work out six days a week i
have my friends nico and hunter they
literally they
if i'm not feeling it one of them is
feeling if one of them not feeling it
i'm dragging us to it yeah this is like
big guys also you know they are they are
very fiction
so they took you in
that's not a joke
what's your family say about it
supportive uh my mom she got the bmi
surgery before me so i watched her go
through it with dieting she cheats a lot
on the diet so yeah you know she does
she's not where she wants to be but
she's miles ahead of where she is your
whole family big yeah yeah besides like
my step sister but yeah basically like
heart problems all that
runs heavy well it's the only thing that
runs in my family you're starting to
trend though they're gonna see you doing
it you know and hopefully it motivates
them i really hope so and even my fitter
friends are becoming more fit seeing the
dedication
yeah yeah yeah
like we're all building each other up
and that's like the true meaning of
[ __ ] friendship right there yeah
that's and this is more um
like this is the kind of body positivity
i think that's important it's 100
percent being real positive about
making your body better that's what the
positivity should be it's about being
healthy because so then in terms of like
your food intake and all that kind of
stuff so are you like but are you
comfortable like do you ever feel like
i'm not i don't i haven't eaten what i
want to eat are you like do you have it
um you know like you're not torturing
yourself no no no like i'm not
i it's really
there's a lot of keto stuff that you can
work around like you know when i got to
town i wanted to try fat burger so i got
like lettuce on like the lettuce on the
bottom yeah yeah yeah all that there's
stuff like that which that's even a
treat then yeah in and out burger yet no
i've never had it this is my taste time
but like this you got to go like this
yeah
like this make sure you don't have your
erection though when you walk in the
field i feel like this is wwf what would
their names be like what would they what
would their tag team partner name be
like that's what we got to find yeah the
bang brothers
[Laughter]
that's a real tag team typhoon
earthquake oh really typhoon earthquake
that's nerdy tugboat
i gotta be honest
you flew in from where i flew in from
chicago that's not close there's one way
only one way to end this bad boy and
it's you getting your hands on him yeah
now he has an erection right now but
that'll go away
hopefully
or it's gonna get bigger stevie i
brought you this oh thank you it's a
participation medal
[Laughter]
well we're so
proud you're [ __ ] killing it i really
don't understand i don't i really don't
think you guys could understand the
impact you have on my life literally we
love it man uh and he said this is your
first time on a plane first time ever on
an airplane you know i got to fly first
class that was pretty nice
it was a small difference
no you should be flying first place and
uh tell them about that i thought
theo just blew a gasket
he was like what's up
i don't have any felonies so theo can't
give me any money
but yeah
like wow
yeah did you bring your participation
[Laughter]
[Music]
when you went to the pier okay so i got
into town i went straight to santa
monica pier because obviously ocean
boulevard you know it's it's the famous
place to go yeah i'm walking i'm taking
pictures doing the tourist thing and
this homeless lady you know a lot of
homeless a lot of homeless here yeah
walks up to me and looks at me
he goes
you transgendered oh and i'm like
welcome
[Music]
yeah were you in that singlet walking
down santa monica yeah like from the
back black dude's gonna walk up to you
like what's up girl
with cnn girls guys you gonna turn
around with the beard they're gonna be
like goddamn
my bad
i will rip it on theo but he was
actually at his netflix taping yeah oh
and now he's going to go to nashville
for the night that's my first ever
comedy show to go so that's a good one
to go to man beautiful yeah i got you
know i got to lead up meet a lot of the
podcast you know community there oh nice
brother the guy next to me he was
talking was like i love theo but i
really like bert crasher yeah and i'm
like
okay
did you get did you meet theo or no no i
didn't get to i went to the first of the
two shows and i figured he had a yeah
the second one yeah yeah that's great he
was hoping some some ladies would have
recognized oh yeah did you get
recognized from the i was hoping i was
walking around i was you know i was
looking good i had my new shirt on
you know but if i didn't meet a if i met
a nice nashville girl you know i could
have a little baby on the way
stevie's line
dude you're gonna get some now though
you can get some slide in your dms now
man hopefully you will you will for sure
don't you think nick some ladies come
out oh definitely we should start a
dating segment with him for sure losing
weight
have you had a girlfriend before yeah i
only had one like one long-term
girlfriend a couple years ago but what
happened
uh you know i was 17 and when you're 17.
you think [ __ ] the girls the world
and yep turns out not to be yeah
i feel like there's more to that story
we'll close out with once king
understanding it this might be an energy
dropper uh after after that but we'll
we'll see what he see
hey doa brandon got a king of stinger
here zach i'm from michigan
uh unfortunately i'm a lions fan you
know my dad was a big lions fan growing
up so i carried the tradition
and now i have kids of my own
and uh i just wanted to know if i should
king it or sting it on uh making them
lions fans should i jump on another
bandwagon right now
or should i remain a lions fan
gang buzz buzz
tell them
i'm upstairs
i'm
[Music]
yeah man don't put that curse on them
kids
become a packers fan a bears fan
there's another team did you say he
lived in michigan
did he say i mean yeah but those kids
don't have they don't need that curse
they suck they're never good yeah but no
i i but i think they should stay detroit
fans stay loyal yeah because it will
happen it happens for every franchise
it's never happened for detroit but it
will
it will i mean it does yeah i hope
you're right it's one years old i mean
they got 18 years
but you don't want your one-year-old to
grow up like just cheering for losers
all the time yeah but they can go to the
game but they're always losing so he's
like dad why don't we ever win it's the
experience of going to the game and
being a part of that for sure you ever
been to the game where your team wins
all the time
uh yeah
so that that basically does it um i
didn't want to say this in the beginning
but there was some breaking sad news uh
norm mcdonald passed away what what
no [ __ ] way from what uh i i haven't
seen him just getting blown up
i saw him uh
i saw him this morning right before
cobra at the comedy store yeah he i
didn't know he's a degenerate gambler he
was like telling me what things to bet
on and [ __ ] i was like what we don't
know a lot of things about no you have
no idea we don't know what's going on in
their lives
but you know well r.i.p to him he was a
great performer legend just a legendary
dude and saturday live when he was on
the news desk legend they even had that
fun little show with him and uh adam
eggett they had i love that you know
right my favorite part it was normic
mcdonald live favorite podcast of all
time like i might cry they turn it into
a netflix show and [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] and
so like you know our heart goes out to
his family and and all the fans and all
the people that have like watched him
you know throughout the years he's been
a legend for so long and you know so we
celebrate his life and you know uh we we
we're glad that we had the opportunity
oh dude even have a conversation even
though it was some terrible betting
picks i still love the dude man
you know what i'm saying he's a legend
legend
he would tell stories how like he'd get
his check from saturday night live he'd
go from new york to
uh at uh atlantic city yeah
he'd lose it in a week weekend
hilarious
i've actually done that in vegas i'm
playing a vegas room and i've lost
whatever money i was going to make
well you're going to like blackjack
no i like to play crap and then i find
myself in the like then you then i have
to use that uh you know the little card
they give you to go to the the employee
buffet yeah and i'm just in there like
am i what i'm gonna do i'm losing all my
money
i'll be at the bud light event center
that's right outside the arena where the
spurs play it's not where the spurs play
it's right outside it literally
connected to it bud light event center
in san antonio texas one show friday one
show saturday i got derek poster and
chappelle lacy our boy david lucas the
squad's out there my man for you if you
want to come my fly out you'll be with
me in the green room yeah i got you man
for real yup i'm gonna put you at the
emma hotel fly out you my god
yo hang out the crew yeah you get the
full experience man
coach middle seat though but come in
you're flying
southwest yeah yeah no i got you i got
you that's great yeah and i'll be in
that's next friday and saturday so if
you want to come in just friday or
saturday we'll talk after the show okay
i got you brother
dope and uh we're going to try to hook
them up to go to the comedy store
tonight too perfect yeah um sweet eric
dates yeah boston 23rd to the 25th laugh
laugh laughs boston check that out yeah
it'll be fun stevie september 24th
austin texas
for the moon tower
comedy festival yeah scissor bros yep
yeah
man you should do 15 minutes in the
beginning stevie do that act that's how
i start stand up we do live podcasts i
do 10 minutes
that's how i got it remember brandon in
the early years
not louis ck 10 000 l's tough but
if you're bombing ten thousand a row
this ain't for you you know yeah but we
love you guys theo we miss you my man so
goddamn proud of you keep crushing we'll
see you in san antonio love you guys
brennan and theo fighter and wait i
gotta go in and go hard in the paint i
do not think i am in flow black rifle
coffee i'm ready to go i need a sponsor
i am a monster about to open up with
this at my concerts flow is contagious
browser outrageous thicker than girls
that are instagram famous damn hungry
like i'm fresh off keto seeing red like
andrew santino every song i hit like the
great bambino burning ate the queso and
the quesoritos but everything's gonna be
fine
hate on me i do not mind
theo looking like the type of dude that
got a pack of matches in his pockets at
all times they sliding into my dms a
couple of you tribal couldn't beat him
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want to smoke like joey diaz meaning
y'all edible just got my eyebrows
threaded and i'm feeling incredible
brandon son hit me up he said it's too
loud in the club can you pick me up king
and the sting
king and the stink oh yeah king and the
sting beast
[Music]
on a string
[Music]
you ready oh you ready yeah are you
ready yes sir let's get it on yeah oh
look it's stevie stevens jim godson
stevie's still got it
you're still
here
let's go stevie
cif champ over here you still got it you
still got it
that was a pretender
you told you [ __ ] bobby
you